è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuto e questo
nuovo video io sono fuori j
e oggi siamo il nuovo blog cercherò di
essere un po sbrigativo questa volta
perché c'è veramente tantissime cose da
dirvi
e in un blog a meno che non duri 40
minuti non ce la faccio quindi cerco di
stringere più possibile direi di
cominciare con la parata della settimana
che tra l'altro la settimana scorsa non
ho fatto e vi stavate fucilando perché
non ho fatto a parte la settimana
scusate me ne sono completamente
dimenticato comunque ragazzi la con hard
della settimana e questa fatta da luigi
o mio dio un maschio che sa disegnare
incredibile comunque ragazzi prima di
passare alle domande
volevo dirvi una cosa che di sicuro farà
gioire mezzo mondo
c'è il punto posta quindi ragazzi da
adesso in avanti per chi vuole farlo
potete inviarmi pacchi che aprirò
durante i prossimi blog e l'indirizzo è
quello inviarmi pacchi lo trovate sotto
nella descrizione l'ultima settimana
comunque ragazzi è stata fatta per
temporeggiare diciamo temporeggiare
perché ultimamente non stanno uscendo
videogame non sta uscendo variamente
niente che mario per grazia di dio è
finito
vabbè abbiamo happy with just dance
ovviamente però parte quelle e il blog
parte quelle non c'è nient'altro perché
tutte le altre serie le dobbiamo
cominciare a partire dal 3 settembre che
esce outlast così come usciranno appunto
amnesia machine for peace
among the slip e huntsman di orphanage
che la casa produttrice mia risposta e
mi manderà la demo e poi lo giocherò
completamente quando uscirà la versione
completa
poi avanti dovranno uscire tutti gli
altri in verbis virtus poi c'è just
dance 2014 che uscirà anche quello e poi
si spera che uscirà si iscrive il naso
maistre che molti si sono già sono
rimasti dispiaciuti e finito
scribblenauts ma sta per uscire il nuovo
scribblenauts quindi ragazzi non vi
preoccupate che di ragazzi le news sono
finite direi che possiamo passare a
rispondere alle domande
la prima domanda alla quale voglio
rispondere la domanda che mi è stata
fatta di più nelle ultime due settimane
ed è la seguente come fa fabi j a
caricare video senza la linea allora due
settimane fa mi avete fatto questa
domanda perché è praticamente abbiamo
detto che la linea nel mio quartiere
sarebbe andata via per due settimane
quindi ho detto ragazzi ho registrato
sette video tutti entro fine settimana
prima che mi sa che in una linea in modo
che vi possa caricare un video ogni due
giorni
ma come fai a caricare milioni due
giorni se ti staccano la linea
oggi è il 31 agosto deciso deciso di
caricare un video così è deciso di farlo
uscire il 7 settembre per dire lo posso
fare con la funzione pianificata a
youtube praticamente to cariche un video
o per gli mette dice youtube quando
pubblicarlo cioè video finisce di
caricare ma non si pubblica rimane
oscurato
privato praticamente fino a che non
arriva la data che voi mettete quindi io
ho fatto sette video prima che vi sta
cazzona li na li ho caricati tutti in
pianificata prima che vista castro li na
e io pianificati un giorno sì e un
giorno no così da soli anche senza che
io avessi a riina si sono pubblicati uno
ad uno
nell'arco di due settimane quindi
smettetela di mandare segnalazioni a
mistero perché poi bark per ri deve fare
un servizio su una cosa che vi ho già
spiegato io quindi state tranquilli non
usati poteri di merlino non ho potuto la
linea qualche mio amico anche se ci
avevo pensato sinceramente non l'ho
fatto
mister due in pc e fa vi risponde come
si chiama la località dove sei andato
sono andato a pian di novello che è un
paesino in montagna sull'appennino
pistoiese c'è una roba nel senso che tu
esci di di notte e se non trovino slider
me sei fortunato e poi sono stato
qualche giorno al mare in spagna a
calella che è una città che sulla costa
vicino a barcellona comunque dice smile
fa vi risponde fa vi porti gli occhiali
tra l'altro ragazzi in spagna mi sono
fatto fare questo che è esageratamente
figo mi calza a pennello sulle cuffie
[Musica]
adesso andro motto fare risponde
vervisch virtus quello della magia
comando vocale uscirà a settembre poi
una serie dato che un gioco fighissimo
spacciate per farglielo leggere lo so
state tranquilli farò anche imberbi
spinto spacca mostrato evidenti in
troppi e se lo farà assolutamente perché
reputavo figo il gioco soltanto la demo
quindi il gioco ufficiale sarà un
qualcosa da paura quindi lo farò
assolutamente sandvik ita se volevi
scrivere sandwitch sappi che hai
sbagliato e parecchio
comunque poi vi risponde nuovi geni hai
mai letto libri or non da piccolo ero
appassionatissimo aspettate cosa cielo
nella passionalissima di questi che sono
piccoli brividi da piccolo né leggevo ma
tipo mi alzavo la mattina invece di fare
colazione con latte biscotti mi mangia
un picco libri ma forse mi sa che anche
per quello che mi è rimasta la passione
degli horror anche negli anni seguenti
daniele corletto fuori risponde ti rendi
conto che i tuoi scritti su youtube
riempirebbero san siro stadio di serie a
e rimarrebbero 15mila persone fuori
sì sì zio però le persone fuori e ho
spedito e tj pils fa vi risponde in
vacanza e punito e quanti hanno
riconosciuto si è successo in spagna
come diavolo è possibile che mi abbiano
riconosciuto in spagna io non lo so ma
ho dovuto firmare due autografi e fare
due foto in spagna
non ho neanche capito io perché comunque
si perchè non fai un setup video della
tua stanza
questa è un'altra cosa che mi continuato
a chiedere ormai da millenni e dire che
è meglio che lo faccia perché sono
continuerete a chiedermelo
quindi ragazzi per un paio di minuti
sarete i miei occhi ok ragazzi ci siamo
questa dovrebbe dovrebbe tra virgolette
essere la mia camera dico dovrebbe
perché l'ordine e spettacolare perciò
prime non vi dico cosa c'è qui dietro
non lo so neanch'io se dovesse sincero
comunque questo è l'armadio che c'è
questa è la posizione che vedete voi
sempre in teoria la mia camera è questo
come potete vedere non è un castello
megagalattica una camera che se fai tre
passi arrivi da una parte all'altra
vabbè comunque vi faccio vedere un
attimo cose oscure che non avete mai
visto
c'è ad esempio allora qua c'è la
stampante cesto pezzo quando l'avete mai
visto né scrivania sarebbe questa qua in
basso ad essere sulla stampante questa
la chitarra
poi c'è qua il ventilatore perché di
notte ragazzi sembra di essere un
ghiacciolo nel forno non so se rendo
l'idea
poi fa c'è un dollaro americano penso
sia vero ce l'ho da secoli piantato liti
questo sono io da piccolo come quello
che avete fatto già notare come se non
lo sapessi poi qua ci sono pacchetti di
sigarette perché una volta facevo la
collezione non un fumo per chi lo chiede
non mi fa parecchio schifo però i
pacchetti erano belli e quindi li tenevo
tipo questo comunque la foto questo
questo sarebbe il death note quello che
faccio vedere un intento solo che è
diciamo inscatolato tengo qui per non
rovinarlo perché le robe le tengo
abbastanza bene perché ci tengo poi la
soci sono questa è la mensola che vedete
sempre in alto la c'è un cuore che mi
sono regalato io quando ero piccolo da
solo da forever alon overnight con
scritto ti voglio bene perché
effettivamente il mi voglio bene questa
è l'angolo diciamo nel canale così mi
piace chiamarlo perché tengo tutte le
cose del canale questa estate che fango
sul letto che non si vede no questo lo
slider che de scatolato qualche blog fa
queste ragazze sono tutte le novelle che
che mi avete inviato perché mi sono
arrivate tre nutella di tre partito
aperto
questa invece quella dello speciale
me la sono mangiata tutta giocando è pp
questi sono gli occhiali che avete visto
prima questo è il pupazzo che ho già
fatto vedere questo lo conoscete tutti
questo che cazzo ci fai o comunque
questo stile non sai cosa ci fa stich
sulla mensola sull'angolo del canale
comunque va lo tengo lì perché è figo ma
direi che possiamo tornare all ultima
cosa queste sono le pagine this land che
avete già notato tra l'altro si sa chi
sia accorto che le manca addirittura una
perché le pagine dovrebbero essere otto
manca la mia l'on
perché non si sa come l'ho persa ce le
teniamo tutte qua tutte 8 in un plico
solo e quando lo attaccate una scomparsa
non si sa come questo è rimasto un
mistero e non la trovo non la trovo più
non so dove comunque va bene prima o poi
dai parola quindi ragazzi questa era la
mia stanza non è che sia così enorme
diciamo che a grandezza normale più che
altro un po un casino quando quando
ballo su just dance perché non tutto
spazi in cui muovermi però lo faccio lo
stesso cena rapine in quel poco che ho
riesco a muovermi decentemente
quindi ragazzi le domande sono più di te
qui spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
come al solito ricordate per chi mi
vuole inviare i fatti che aprirà nei
prossimi blog da quello prossimo è nei
prossimi a venire ancora virili solo
trovate nella descrizione del video da
domani happy uil e dalla prossima
settimana inizieranno tutte le serie
nuove quindi ragazzi preparatevi sarà
fantastico quindi ragazzi se vi do è
piaciuto lasciate un commento vi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate una descrizione se non si
davvero i siti gli scrive the 15 vediamo
un prossimo video
[Musica]